BEN CHU: Hey, guys.
Welcome to today's session
of Google Author Talks.
My name is Ben Chu.
I'm here to introduce a dear
friend of mine, whom I've know
for the last 15 years.
It's been really wonderful
seeing his life's journey
unfold over the last decade.
He'll be talking about something
that's pretty close
and dear to my heart, as a guy
with a kid, another kid on the
way, and my wife, and--
just balancing the demands of
family versus my spiritual
passions and hobbies, and
work of course, has
always been a struggle.
And I feel like that's fairly
common here at Google.
So Gary's actually given
this talk to many
large companies before.
He has a lot of experience
doing it.
So I'm really excited here
it for the first time.
I'm sure it will be
very practical--
lot of good wisdom here.
So let's everyone give him
a warm Google welcome.
Gary Kunath.
[APPLAUSE]
GARY KUNATH: Thank you.
It's really my pleasure
to be here.
It's my first time on
the Google campus.
So--
this is really quite a treat
to see everybody playing
volleyball.
And when I started at AT&T, you
didn't play volleyball at
AT&T. You just came to work.
And that was it-- boom, done.
The reason I'm here-- and
listen, I'm not a
psychiatrist.
And I'm not a psychologist.
I'm not going to talk
about rainbows,
unicorns, and lollipops.
What I am is a business guy.
And I started from
the ground up.
And I was hungry.
I thought net worth was the
secret to life worth.
And I worked really
hard for it.
But I made some very critical
mistakes along the way.
And those mistakes cost me
in my personal life.
And the reason I'm here, it's my
passion now, to share that
story with others.
Because my goal's to have
everybody have the greatest
life they can have.
I want to maximize joy
and contentment
in everybody's life.
And I want to share with you
how I figured it out.
I was just so thankful
I figured out
before it was too late.
Because some people don't.
So last month, I was riding
a plane from Montreal.
And I happened to sit
near this guy.
And I don't--
I never really talk to people.
Not that I'm unsociable,
I just--
I like to read.
But the guy started
to talk to me.
And he went, what you do?
What do you do?
That kind of stuff.
That's probably why don't
talk to people.
Because it's boring.
But so we finally got to the
point where I said, well,
where are you headed?
And he goes, oh man.
He goes, I'm going to China.
Three weeks, man.
I'm going to China.
He goes, it's awesome
over there.
He goes, and from there, I'm
just going to scoot over to
Singapore for another
three weeks.
He goes, this job--
I've seen the world.
It's the best job ever.
He goes, I'm going to come over
for maybe about a week,
maybe three days.
I haven't decided yet.
And then I'm going to go to
South America for a month.
Now it was funny.
Because as I'm listening
to this guy--
if I was in my early 20s, I know
exactly what I would have
been thinking.
I would have said, Oh,
I want to be you.
You are so cool!
You're going to everywhere.
It's what I dreamed of.
I want that job.
But I'm not my 20s.
And I knew better.
And I knew that what he was
giving me was what I would
call psychological camouflage
for what was really going on
in his life, which is not an
uncommon thing, by the way.
And I asked him one question.
I just looked at him.
And I said, so tell me, with all
this travel, how was that
affected your relationship
at home with your
wife and your kids?
And it was dead silence.
I'm not kidding you.
The color drained out
of this guy's face.
He just went, whew.
He goes, I come home--
decisions are made in the
house, I have no say.
He goes, I go to discipline the
kids, they look at me like
I'm a stranger.
But what was amazing to me is
as I saw the pain on this
guy's face-- and here he is
trying to camouflage this, as
though he's got this
great life.
But when he comes home, there's
nothing going on.
And I felt bad for the guy.
And I also understood the guy.
Because for short period in
my life, that was me.
And I knew what that was like.
I know how that feels.
And sometimes you convince
yourself you're doing this for
the good of your family.
You're sacrificing so
your kids and your
family don't have to.
You're sacrificing so they
can have a better life.
And in part, that's true.
But the reality this,
they just want you.
So I want to talk about not so
much about making a living.
I've done the corporate thing.
I did the entrepreneurial
thing.
I made my bones.
I'm fine.
But I'm going to talk
about making a life.
It doesn't take that much
effort to make a living.
People do it all
over the world.
But making a life is
not that easy.
And that's what I want
to spend some time to
talk with you about.
It used to be that people
thought, including myself,
that professional well being
drives personal well being.
And I believed this too.
I attended a retirement
party of a CEO of
a Fortune 100 company.
You would know it.
I won't mention it.
And I listened to the CEO's
retirement speech.
And I will never forget it.
He got up there.
And it was a room full of
maybe 300-400 people.
And he sat there, and he goes,
I know many of you in this
room want to know what it
takes to do my job.
He goes, and I'm going to tell
you right now what it takes to
have my job.
And it was funny because
I watched the crowd.
You could see the young
stallions going, all right
baby, here we go.
Launch pad to the top.
So they're just waiting
for this.
And he goes, four weeks ago, I
walked my oldest daughter down
the aisle to give her
hand in marriage.
He said, and as I was walking
her down the aisle, I realized
I couldn't tell you what
her favorite color is.
He goes, I realized I couldn't
tell you her favorite book
that you ever read or any
book that she ever read.
I couldn't tell you the last
name of her best friend.
He goes, that's what it
takes to do my job.
And if you want it,
you could have it.
And what struck me about
that was this--
here's a guy who was,
no question, was
a captain of industry.
No question.
And yet he wasn't even a
deckhand in his own life.
And he was-- it was a
combination of frustration and
anger, but mostly at himself.
Because he let it get
away from him.
He knew there were memories that
he was never ever going
to get to make.
There was events in his life
that he was not there for.
And you can't get them back.
Yeah, he's got cash.
He's got big, big houses, nice
cars, private schools.
But he's got nothing.
And I've always believed--
to me, it didn't make sense to
have to love either your work
life or love your home life.
I wanted to love
my whole life.
So I figured out for me what
the top ways are to drive
happiness and to be happy.
Because I believe that it's this
equation is really the
other way around.
I believe it's personal well
being the drives professional
well being.
I live that myself.
When I started to focus, when
I was focusing on the
professional well begin,
yeah, I was kicking it.
I was-- pisch!
Money was coming in.
Everything you would
ever want, I had.
The problem was when I got home,
what you want there, I
didn't have.
It cost me.
So I said, I got to fix this.
So I focused on personal
well being.
And what I learned was this--
the happier you are in your
life, the better you are in
every other aspect
of your life.
And that includes work.
I was a smarter entrepreneur.
I worked better.
I was happier.
I had more fun.
I was more successful--
all that stuff because
I focused on
personal well being.
I put that first.
So let's talk more about that.
You're very lucky to
be here at Google.
You are.
Because Google, I can see just
by the short time I've been on
the campus, values its people.
Now, let's be honest--
they get their pound
of flesh too.
OK?
It's not a secret why they want
you to stay 12 hours a
day and have dinner and
everything else.
Because you go and bang
out some more work.
I get it.
But it's all right.
It's OK.
That's fine.
I'm all for that.
As long as you're
happy, right?
But, to me, it's what happens
when you leave here.
Now you look at this.
I'll walk through
this with you.
But this is the landscape
outside of Google.
"Some companies believe we can
ignore the deep realities of
human existence.
We can pretend that
emotions are not
part of our work lives.
We can pretend we don't have
families or health crisis or
deep worries.
In essence, companies want to
take the complexity of human
life and organize it away.
It's not part of the story
we want to believe.
People can be viewed as machines
and controlled to
perform with the same efficiency
and predictability.
And in our machine
organizations, we try to
extinguish individuality
in order to
reach our goal of certainty.
We trade uniqueness for
control and barter our
humanness for petty performance
measures."
It's interesting.
You look at some of these
experiential companies that
rely on the customer
experience,
for instance, airlines.
What was it?
Marriott?
No.
Ritz Carlton.
Singapore Airlines.
And there's another chain
that wanted--
they invested $6 million to
teach people how to be
themselves.
You wonder where did
the wheels come
off the cart there?
At what point did they say,
no, don't be you because
nobody likes you.
So be something else.
Where did they gum
up the gears?
It's because some of these
companies try to do force fit
these people into these molds.
They want-- but they hire these
wonderfully gifted and
talented people.
And then they force them into
this mold-- say, listen, when
a customer says this,
you say that.
When they say this,
you say this.
You say that.
And that's how it goes.
And you get rid of this
individual freedom that makes
people great.
So bringing humanity back to the
business is a huge issue
for many companies out there.
Now you look at the landscape
of the people.
Interesting enough, American
Psychology Association-- "48%
of employees say their employers
don't value good
work life balance." Some,
I know, don't.
I've been there.
I've seen it.
Some pretend.
They put nice posters
in a lunchroom.
And it looks good for the profit
sharing plan and the
annual report.
You have to get in underneath
the sea what's
really going on.
But this is a really
huge issue.
So here's what people
are valuing--
well being of their
families, and
themselves, outside of work.
And yet many of them
don't believe the
companies feel the same.
The Aspen Institute--
61% of the people surveyed there
said they're not living
the American dream.
75% think it's broken.
70% of the people, and this is
out of the Families and Work
Life Institute said they would
trade promotions and pay
increases for family
well being.
Over 70% of Americans
over the age of 30
get no regular exercise.
And only 14% take vacations
of two weeks or longer.
Now you think, oh,
that's crazy.
No, it isn't crazy.
That's what's going on.
I find people put more time
into the planning their
vacation than they do
planning their life.
It boggles my mind.
Why is that?
In Europe, you would never
see a 14 day vacation.
If you said 14 days, you would
have a revolution.
OK?
So here are what I see as some
tremendous life limiters.
These are things that bring
us back and bring us down.
Regret over the past--
worrying about what happened
that you can't change anymore.
Regret over the past-- oh,
should of done this.
Should have done-- oh, if
I'd only done that.
You've got that go.
Resentment and envy
in the present--
resentment and envy are the two
emotions that it's been
medically proven will literally
dissolve or
eradicate your immune system.
They are physically unhealthy
emotions for you.
And fear the future--
fear of the future
is a big one.
It's why we don't do things.
It's why we don't
roll the dice.
take chances.
It's interesting.
As we've evolved over the last
one and a half million years
our brains have developed a
capacity to simulate outcomes.
We can simulate outcomes.
Our ancestors could not
simulate outcomes.
They would have to look
at a fire go, yeah,
that's pretty hot.
My foot's burning.
We can go, yeah, no.
It makes sense.
We'd better stay
away from that.
We can simulate.
But the problem is, even though
that's a beautiful gift
to have, the problem is when
we simulate outcomes in our
mind, we usually make them more
negative than they are.
So we don't do things.
We think they're going to be
worse than they really are.
I don't know you've ever done
things, and you said, well, I
never thought I could
run a 5K.
And then you do.
And you go, whoa, can't
believe I did that.
So that's just one of the
things that we do.
So fear of the future is
a huge, huge issue.
And it is a major
life limiter.
Now, the science
of happiness--
Let me talk about this.
Because when I used to think
about-- well, because I used
to do talks--
and business talks,
value creation.
One of the businesses I owned
was sales training, high-end
sales training company.
We used to do all the sales
training for the top companies
all over the world.
And I used to think about, OK,
well how did I not focus on
life worth?
How did I turn this corner?
And people would ask me that.
And I would tell them, this
is what I've experienced.
And this is what I know the
leads to a great life.
But then they'd say, well,
what's the science behind it?
And it really stumped me.
So I went and I did some
research on the
science behind it.
And here's what I know
about happiness--
we have the capability.
The other thing that our minds
have evolved into is allowing
us to have the capability
to synthesize
happiness in our minds.
And this comes out of
Harvard University.
There's two forms
of happiness.
There's natural happiness.
You're happy when you
get what you want.
OK?
Fair statement.
But then there's synthetic or
synthesized happiness, where
you're happy when you don't
get what you want.
That's a big deal.
It gives us the ability--
and I'll show you.
It allows us-- this one thing
allows us the ability to take
situations that aren't very
pleasant or are negative and
turn them, in our minds, into
a situation that are OK.
I'll give an example.
Another study, I think was out
of Villanova, where they
looked at an individual who won
a $200 million lottery and
individual became
a paraplegic.
And they said, which do you
think had the happier outcome?
Well, it's pretty obvious.
You might say, well, of course,
the lottery winner.
But the truth be told, at the
end of 12 months, they went
and measured the happiness
of each one.
There was absolutely no
statistical difference in the
happiness between
the paraplegic
of the lottery winner.
None.
Because that's the
skill we have.
It's almost like a psychological
immune system we
have in our head, where we can
take situations, and we could
make the best of them
regardless.
I was at the X-Games for
the paraplegics.
This guy was doing the
downhill slalom.
And I asked him.
I was fascinated.
This guy was unbelievable.
And he was going downhill in
the giant slalom skiing.
I got to talk him.
And he turned to me, and he
said, my life is better than
your best vacation.
And you know what?
And he meant it.
And you could look at this guy
and say, how could that be?
But in his mind, there was
not even a question.
And I said, well,
well why can't
everybody feel like that.
And the answer is, we can.
We all have this capability
in our head.
The key is some activate
it better than others.
So I'm activate a better
than others.
Sometimes it takes a significant
emotional event in
our life to really ground
us and say, what
am I thinking about?
I'm worrying about
all these things.
And these things aren't
important at all.
So when you look at the science
of happiness, you look
at it like this.
50% of your happiness
is a set point.
It's like when you're born.
You have green eyes.
You have brown eyes.
You have blue eyes.
Done.
I mean that's it.
Boom.
10% percent of your happiness
is circumstantial.
But 40% of your happiness
is derived
from intentional activity.
In other words, there are
literally things you can do to
be happier.
And why you wouldn't want to
be happier is beyond me.
But there are things
you can do.
People want to be happier.
But sometimes they
don't know how.
So here is what I
know to be true.
These are my 10 points
of life.
These are the things I know
and research supports will
absolutely maximize joy and
contentment in your life.
Now I'm going to go into the
ones that are highlighted in
red more deeply.
But I'll cover them.
And I'll just touch on these
for time issues.
But money doesn't
make you rich.
Expressing gratitude matters.
Good goes around.
Practicing the art
of savoring.
The power of perspective.
That literally saved my life.
I have to tell you.
The belief in something
bigger than you.
Life is fun.
And fun is good.
Relationship refinement,
thinning the herd.
We'll talk about that.
And being your authentic self.
And then, preparing a last
lecture for your family.
Now let me just touch on the
ones that aren't highlighted.
Gratitude matters.
Gratitude is one of the single
most important things that
contribute to one's
happiness--
going and being grateful
for what you have.
I don't know this, but sometimes
we can take for
granted things that we
have that we should
never take for granted.
But because we have them, we
just overlook them because
they're part of our lives.
I always.
I'm a big believer in thank-you
notes, a huge
believer in thank-you notes.
And I mean handwritten, not
the electronic ones.
I know that's a--
to me, that's like
a drive-through
window kind of thing.
I like the handwritten written
notes I make a point the write
handwritten notes thanking
people for just doing
something that mattered to me.
And you know what?
It takes me five minutes or less
and the cost of a stamp.
And they keep it forever.
I literally have boxes
of thank you
cards that I've received.
And I look at them when
I feel crappy.
I read them.
It's such a little
thing to do.
But it's such a huge thing do.
And I make that a point.
All my kids have thank
you cards.
Everybody has thank you cards.
That's what we do.
Now, believing in something
bigger than you--
I'm not try to make a spiritual
comment here.
But people want to be part
of something bigger than
themselves.
My suspicion is that's probably
a big part of why
people join Google.
You're part of something bigger
than you, something
that really is changing
things.
That's a big thing.
But on the other hand, on the
life side, I hate to say this,
but bad things happen
to good people.
Adversity plays no favorites.
And adversity finds us all.
You will not miss it.
It will come to you, if
it has not already.
And these things can be big--
death, loss of a loved one,
financial ruin, addictions,
victim of a crime, disabling
accident.
These things are huge.
And I believe they're so
much bigger than us.
So it's important for me, I
think, to believe in something
bigger than you.
Because these things will
crush you if you
try to stand alone.
And the truth be told, we need
and adversity in our lives.
We need it.
Because it's the only way
you could find out
who you really are.
Look, anyone can be a rock star
when life is perfect.
But when life isn't so
perfect, then the
real you shows up.
That's how you find
out who you are.
You can either be a camper, a
climber, or quitter when it
comes with adversity, if you
were to use a mountain
climbing analogy.
Some people just quit in
the face of adversity.
Some people camp, hole up, cover
themselves up, hoping
everything blows away.
And some people climb.
But we need adversity
in our lives.
I can tell you.
When my father passed
away- and my father
and I were very close.
And he had brain cancer.
And I was in the hospital
room with him, and--
I was CEO of my own company.
I graduated from the best
business schools.
I had lectured at the best
I had money.
I had contacts I had juice.
But let me tell you something.
I was so far out of my
league on this one.
I can't even describe the
feeling of complete and abject
helplessness fine had watching
my father die.
And I could do nothing
about it.
Nothing.
And if I didn't believe that
there was some, something
bigger at play in that room, I
don't know how I would have
gotten through that.
It still is a tough thing.
But I'm a big believer that
believing in something bigger
than you will put you in a
position to come out OK on
life's adversities that
you will get handed.
Being your authentic self--
when I first left--
I left AT&T. And I started
my own business.
It's pretty scary, right?
I was a single income.
I had a wife.
And I three small kids.
If I failed, we didn't eat.
Fear is a great motivator.
If I failed, we didn't have
a house to live in.
Failure was not an
option for me.
So when I went into this
consulting business--
I don't know what
I was thinking.
Maybe I was stupid.
I don't know.
Actually, my first desk was my
six-year-old son's Play-Doh
Playskool desk in my basement.
And I had the little
laptop on it.
I look like Schroeder
from Peanuts.
And when customers would call
me, I didn't want them to
think I'm working under basement
on a Play-Doh desk.
Who wants to put their sales
strategy in the hands of a guy
that's got his desk near
the canned pickles
, down in the basement.
So I remember, I would
answer the phone.
And I'm thinking, I don't know,
consultants they have
high office buildings with
ceiling to floor windows.
And they're over the park.
So I've got to act that way.
So when someone would call, and
I would pick up the phone,
and my dog would bark.
And would go nuts.
I'd go, ah!
And they'd go, was that a dog?
And of course, I'm thinking.
Well, I won't tell them
I have a dog.
Consultants don't have dogs.
They don't like mammals.
They're not human.
So I go, oh yeah, it's a dog.
I'm at the animal research
center at Pfizer.
I made stuff up just because I
didn't want them to think I'm
in my basement.
And what was interesting to me
was after my business became
really successful, I decided
to just be me.
As frightening as that is,
I decided to just be me.
Because I didn't care.
I didn't need business.
I was good.
So when they would call, and the
dog would bark, they'd go,
hey, is that a dog?
I'd go, yeah, it's a dog.
I have two.
They're miniature long-haired
dachshunds.
They're idiots.
They'd go, oh, I have a
dachshund, too, and
that dog's an idiot.
So what I found was
being myself--
not only did it eliminate the
stress of wearing someone
else's face--
it was so liberating for me.
And in life, it's all about
how you show up anyway.
So that was a lesson
that I had learned.
People like authenticity.
People like that.
Customers like it.
Everybody likes authentic.
And then last thing is preparing
a last lecture for
your family.
This comes from a concept called
ethical wills and was
around a long time before Dr.
Randy Pausch of Carnegie
Mellon made it popular.
You may have seen that video.
And he called it
a last lecture.
I had--
I think it's a good
thing to do.
I did that for my son when he
graduated from college.
I wrote--
because people--
you have wills to divide
up your stuff.
But as a parent, I don't want my
kids guessing who I really
was, what I believed, what I
valued, what mattered to me,
what I think is important
in life.
Because you can't always flip
the cards on the table.
You got to show-- you got
to be a dad sometimes.
So I wrote an ethical will
about what I valued.
And I give them that as
a graduation gift.
And actually, believe it or not,
it's printed as I gave it
to him in the book, and he
still has it to this day.
These are some of the
10 points of life
I believe are important.
But now I'll go into the ones
that are more highlighted.
Money doesn't make you rich.
Life worth versus net worth.
Here's what I would tell
you about that.
And let me be clear about
what I'm not saying.
What I'm not saying is,
don't work hard.
Not saying that.
I worked hard.
And I still work hard
when I want to work.
But what I'm saying is, don't
focus on net worth at the
expense of life worth.
And many people do that.
Many people do that.
I know people with tremendously
high net worths
that I would consider miserable
failures as human beings.
And yet I know people that
barely make ends meet, are
barely paying their bills, and
they're some of the most happy
and successful people I know.
What I found when I lectured to
talked a lot of executives
is net worth can be a very
intoxicating spin cycle,
especially when you start
seeing in the
money roll, the bonuses.
Ah, maybe I'll stay
one more year.
Maybe I'll do it.
And it can get you.
Now if you're in the early
phases of your career.
And you're just starting out.
And you got enough money to make
to get things, then, yes,
of course you focus on that.
But there will be a time in your
life when you will have
to choose which governs which.
And I'm telling you the only
reason you care about net
worth that all is to underwrite
life worth.
But sometimes we forget.
I had a friend of mine
who was talking to
this other guy who--
he was a millionaire.
And he was chirping
a little bit.
He was going, yeah,
I have this.
I have that.
And my friend, who wasn't
a millionaire,
was a regular guy.
He goes, yeah, let me
tell something.
I have something you'll
never have.
He goes, what's that?
He goes, I have enough.
And the guy just stopped
in his tracks.
And you know what?
It was a perfect answer.
But that's that hardest thing
for people to figure out.
When do you know you've
had enough.
See when I learned what really
mattered in life
and focused on that.
And that happiness helped me
even more, professionally.
It was when I had nothing.
I had nothing when
I started out.
Then I had something.
That I lost my family because I
was a workaholic, unlike now
where I'm a workafrolic.
OK?
And then I had nothing again.
But that was the most important
lesson I learned.
And you're going to hear many
CEOs come in and tell you they
lost their families.
They got divorced.
They're not going to
tell you this.
They're going to tell you
everything's great.
But everything isn't great.
I've seen them.
I learned the most
important thing.
And that was, when I had
nothing, I learned how to be
happy without anything.
And that was the
most important.
I learned what I did not
need to be happy.
I was perfectly happy that
I didn't have a cool car.
I could get around.
But that forced me to
understand what really mattered.
Life worth versus net worth.
Very, very important piece.
And when you come to terms with
what matters most to you,
and put the priority right
spot, it's a big thing.
Now this is the only
trick I know.
I'm a old guy.
This is the only trick I
know, so bear with me.
No, you don't have vertigo.
It is just my technological
savvy shining through.
But here's what I want
to tell you.
This is true.
People start to live the most
after they have faced death.
And I want play for you a
short video so you can--
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[APPLAUSE]
-Imagine a big explosion as you
climb through 3,000 feet.
Imagine a plane full of smoke.
Imagine an engine going clack,
clack, clack, clack, clack,
clack, clack.
Sounds scary.
Well I had a unique
seat that day.
I was sitting in 1D.
I was the only one who could
talk to the flight attendants.
So I looked at them
right away.
And they said, no problem.
We probably hit some birds.
The pilot had already turned
the plane around.
And we weren't that far.
You could see Manhattan.
Two minutes later, three things
happened at the same time.
The pilot lines up the plane
with the Hudson River.
It's usually not the route.
[LAUGHTER]
-He turns off the engines.
Now imagine being on the
plane with no sound.
And then he says three words,
unemotional three words that I
have ever heard.
He says, brace for impact.
I didn't have to talk to the
flight attendant anymore.
[LAUGHTER]
-I could see it in her eyes.
It was terror.
Life was over.
I want to share with you
three things I learned
about myself that day.
I learned that it all changes
in an instant.
We have this bucket list.
We have these things we
want to do in life.
I thought about all the
people wanted to
reach out that I didn't.
All the fences I
wanted to mend.
All the experiences I wanted
to had, and I never did.
As I thought about that, later
on, I came up with a saying,
which is, I collect bad wines.
Because if the wine is ready
and the person there, I'm
opening it.
I no longer want to postpone
anything in life.
And that urgency, that
purpose, has
really changed my life.
The second thing I learned
that day--
and this as we clear the George
Washington Bridge,
which was by not a lot--
I thought about, wow, I really
feel one real regret.
I've lived a good life.
In my own humanity and mistakes,
I've tried to get
better at everything I try.
But in my humanity, I also
allow my ego to get in.
And I regretted the time I
wasted in things that did not
matter with people
that matter.
I thought about my relationship
with my wife,
with my friends, with people.
And after, as I reflected on
that, I decided to eliminate
negative energy from my life.
It's not perfect.
It's a lot better.
I've not had a fight with
my wife in two years.
It feels great.
I no longer trying
to be right.
I choose to be happy.
The third thing I learned, and
this is as your mental clock
starts going 15, 14, 13.
You could see the
water coming.
I'm saying, please blow up.
I don't want this thing to break
in 20 pieces like you've
seen in those documentaries.
And as we're coming down.
I had a sense of, wow,
dying is not scary.
It's almost like we've
been preparing for
it our whole lives.
But it was very sad.
I didn't want to go.
I love my life.
And that sadness really framed
in one thought, which is, I
only wish for one thing--
I only wish I could see
my kids grow up.
About a month later I was
in the performance by my
daughter, first grader, not
much artistic talent--
yet.
And I'm bawling.
I'm crying.
like a little kid.
And it made all the sense
in the world to me.
I realize, at that point, by
connecting those two dots,
that the only thing that
matters in my life is
being a great dad.
Above all.
Above all, the only goal
I have in life is
to be a good dad.
I was given the gift of a
miracle of not dying that day.
I was given another gift, which
was to be able to see
into the future and come back
and live differently.
I challenge you guys that are
flying today, imagine the same
thing happens on your plane.
And please don't.
But imagine.
And how would you change?
What would you get done that
you're waiting to get done
because you think you'll
be here forever?
How would you change your
relationships and the negative
energy in them?
And more than anything,
are you being the
best parent you can?
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
GARY KUNATH: Puts things
in perspective.
In fact, it was interesting.
Steve Jobs said remembering that
you will eventually die
is the most important tool
you'll ever have to make those
big decisions in life.
All fear of failure, pride,
and enormity of risk, fall
away in the face of death.
The things I used to think
were such big deals, they
weren't big deals.
When I walk through a children's
cancer ward, I'm
ashamed of what I thought
was a big deal or
what bothered me.
My son, who's your age, works
in the medical field.
He's in surgeries.
He had--
he was in a surgery.
And it was a simple
bowel re-section.
I don't know how
they are but--
and earlier in the week, he
had called me in sales.
He goes, Dad, I'm really trying
to figure out how to
make my sales quota, how to
make my sales numbers.
I used to run a sales
training company.
So that was an obvious area
that I knew about, which I
also though was funny.
Because when we lived at home,
he wasn't worried about making
anything, including his bed.
So I thought this was
really a very unique
conversation for him.
Now he's worried about
making something.
And he was really upset by it.
And [INAUDIBLE]
hindsight.
I'm not saying it
was unimportant.
But don't lose sleep over it.
It's not that important.
Of course, I can't tell him.
Some things you just have to
experience before you get it.
I can tell you, but it won't
register until you live it.
And so we talked about that.
We agreed we talk at the
end of the week.
And the end of the week came.
And I sensed there was a
difference in his voice.
And I said, what's--
tell me about what
happened today?
What was your day like?
He said we came out of
surgery today, Dad.
He goes, there was
a guy in there.
He's 32 years old.
He was in for a simple
operation, should have a been
boom, in and out.
They opened him up.
He was covered with cancer.
He said, Dad, his wife is
in the waiting room.
She had two little kids.
She doesn't know that
her husband has a
month, maybe less.
And he doesn't know either.
And he goes, Dad, I have
two little kids.
That guy's my age.
And I said, well, what
you learn from that?
He goes maybe my sales
objectives
aren't that big a deal.
And again, I'm not saying
work is unimportant.
But I'm saying the power of
perspective will save you.
It saved me.
The things I thought
had to be done.
They didn't have to be done.
They could have waited a day.
I didn't have to
miss a birthday
party to do those things.
Are you kidding me?
Never again.
Just to give you some
perspective, this is an
interesting calculation.
Because I know you're young,
think you're bullet proof,
think you're going
to live forever.
Think you got an inordinate
amount of Saturdays left.
Check this out.
Multiply your age by 365,
subtract that from 27,375,
which is on average the days
in a lifespan of 75 years.
And what you get is the number
of days you have
left to wake up.
Now, since I'm older
then you--
see here's how you know--
here's how I knew I was
getting older--
when I went into a music store
and everything I like is $1.
[LAUGHTER]
GARY KUNATH: And I also know I'm
getting older, when I call
it a music store.
That's another way I know
I'm getting older.
But--
50 years old.
Here's the math.
I've broke it down.
That's 1,300 Saturdays.
When you think about it
like that, you don't
want to blow a Saturday.
And let me tell you something.
That's if you make 75.
You may not.
One of the businesses that I'm
in is I own professional
baseball teams.
I don't know if you saw that
in the bio, but I do.
We had opening day at one
of my teams in Brockton,
Massachusetts, the
Brockton Rocks.
And in the office, at the end
of the game, our mascot--
We had a kangaroo
for a mascot.
Don 't ask me why.
Maybe we got a cheap deal
on a kangaroo outfit.
I'm not sure why we have a
kangaroo and what that has to
do with rocks.
But anyway--
So he comes out.
And he's got a Syracuse
University t-shirt on.
And I hadn't met him yet.
And so I go, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Get over here.
I said, what's the deal
the Syracuse?
He goes, well, I went
to Syracuse.
I go, I went to Syracuse.
He goes, well, I was the
mascot at Syracuse.
He goes, I was the orange.
He goes I was Otto the Orange.
I go, I love Otto the Orange.
So we had a great, great time.
This kid was 26 years old.
And we had the best time.
What a delightful guy.
We had a wild time.
And we took a picture.
I was so enamored with this guy,
we took a picture of he
and I in the front office.
Seven months later, he
died of leukemia--
26 years old.
He didn't know we had it.
I didn't know he had it.
His parents didn't
know he had it.
Gone.
26 years old.
I keep . that picture in my
home for two reasons.
One, I never want to
forget this kid.
Because he was such a
vibrant life force.
And two, I never want
to forget that can
go away like this.
It could be all gone in a day.
You're life can change
in a second.
And I don't want miss
one second of life.
Top five regrets of the dying.
This was compiled by 2000
hospice nurses.
Here's what the dying said.
I wished I had courage to live a
life true to myself, not the
life expected of me.
I wished I hadn't
worked so hard.
I wished I had the courage to
express my true feelings.
I wished I had stayed in
touch with my friends.
And this last one kills
me, I wished I
let myself be happier.
Top five of people dying.
They can't have I do over.
Why?
Why must it be then when this
comes to your mind?
That's what made me on a mission
to say, don't let that
happen to you.
Good goes around--
another point of life.
I'm a big believer.
Being a better giver makes you
better getter, as long as you
don't give to get.
I believe that with
all my heart.
I've experienced that.
One of my businesses now is
highly philanthropic, where
every 10 years our goal is to
give a billion dollars to
cause related charities.
Being a better giver makes you
a better getter, as long as
you don't give to get.
Here's how I know
that to be true.
When I was first starting my
first business, The Summit
Group, which was the
sales training.
And I was looking for
that big hat.
In my neighborhood, I would
run to blow off the steam.
And I would pass this woman.
And we'd just say, hi.
Hi.
And go about our business.
And then one day, I got
knock on my door.
And I opened the door.
And it was her.
And she was just as surprised to
see that I lived there as I
was to see that she's
knocking on my door.
And I go, what's up?
She goes, well, I'm
collecting for my
neighbor, whose son has--
he's eight years old.
He has leukemia.
And they're taking him for
treatment at Boston.
And they don't have enough money
for them to stay with
their son during this
treatment period.
So I'm running to raise
money in donations.
And I'm telling you.
I don't know what
made me do this.
To this day, I don't know
what made me do this.
I just looked at her,
and I said, well,
how much do you need?
And she told me.
And I said, wait here.
And I went in and I came back
with a check for the entire
amount, handed it to her.
And I got a call from the kid's
parents that night.
It was a call I'll never
forget-- crying.
They couldn't believe
a stranger had
done this for them.
It was a call I'll
never forget.
But the real part of the story
that is amazing to me is, as
I'm trying to build this
business, I need this one big
hit to get going.
About 30 maybe 45 days
later, I get a call.
It's from the director of
training at Southern
California Edison.
And she's talking about
sales training.
So we had a conversation for 45
minutes on sales training.
At the end of the conversation,
she goes so this
is the ABC Company, right?
And I go, no, this is
the Summit Group.
So goes, I was calling
ABC Company.
I go, well--
So now I'm thinking, ugh.
She goes, I must have dialed
the wrong number.
She goes, but it
doesn't matter.
Because, you know what?
What you talked about,
I really liked.
That turned into a seven
figure contract for me.
That launched my business
at Summit Group.
You can't tell me those
things aren't related.
What are the odds of that?
What are the odds of her not
even saying, is this the
Summit Group up front
in our conversation?
Because if she had said,
that would have said--
or is this ABC company,
I'd have said, no.
That'd have been it.
She'd have hung up
and redialed.
Where are the odds of that?
Good does go around.
In fact, I'd don't know
if you saw this.
This was just recent, where a
woman was shopping and had a
bumper sticker saluting her
husband, who was over in
Afghanistan serving.
She came back to her car.
This a note was taped
to her windshield
along with 40 dollars.
And it said, I noticed
the sticker on the
back of your car.
Take your hero out to dinner
when he comes home.
Thank you both for serving,
him deployed and you for
waiting, United States
veteran, God bless.
That had like two million
hits in about six hours.
That's how good goes around.
I'm a big believer in that.
Practicing the art
of savoring--
one of the things that
I do every day is I
take time to read.
I'll look at the stars.
I'll just sit and look
at the stars.
I'll watch the birds.
My father used to do that.
I'd go, oh man.
Now I'm my father, right?
Now I'm watching birds.
But I just do it.
Because it's easy.
And I take pleasure
in the senses.
I stop and smell fresh
cut grass.
I smell a flower on the way.
I don't let a second go by.
There was a guy in the
Booneville Hotel, up in
Bonneville, New York.
I have a place not
far from there.
And he used to come
in every night.
And every night, he would
order bourbon.
And he was a great guy.
His wife who this guy loved
passionately had passed away
several years back.
And he never really
got over it.
They used to go out dancing
all the time.
He would love to dance.
And I would talk to this guy.
He was a delightful guy.
But then they would come a point
in the evening were he
would turn and go
to the jukebox.
And that was my cue to
give him a space.
He would play one song, L7.
And it was "Harvest Moon"
by Neil Young.
And he would go back, and
he'd sit in his chair.
And his eyes would close.
And his head would do this.
And he physically was there
but wasn't there.
He was mentally transported.
And he was dancing with
his wife, I am sure.
And he was zoned out.
And it was such an unbelievably
beautiful thing
to see, to watch him do that,
and to see every single note
of that song.
He soaked it in, like
it was gold.
And he did that every night.
And it's interesting.
Poor guy passed away
this year.
And I actually, evenings
at my lake house,
I'll play Neil Young.
And I'll do one of these.
Because I know he's
the dancing.
So that's what I do.
But time flies very fast.
I remember exactly being
your age, exactly.
And it blows by like you
wouldn't believe.
And the older you get,
the faster it goes.
I know maybe your parents
say that.
I look at you--
on average, most of you are
much younger than me.
The three greatest gifts you
can give your family.
And they're free.
They're budget friendly.
Whether Google gives you a 10%
bonus or not, you could still
afford these--
time, memories, and tradition.
The three greatest gifts.
Give your family your time.
Time to know you.
Time to enjoy you.
As I said earlier, I thought,
oh, I'd better get them brand
name sneakers and all that.
No, no, no--
they want you.
They want you.
Memories--
memories, to me, are the most
powerful life force we have
available to us.
When you think about it,
memories have kept prisoners
of war alive.
Memories have brought families
together when
they were miles apart.
They've helped heal the sick.
They've sped up recovery
times.
Memories are a powerful tool.
And frankly, in the
end, members are
all you'll ever have.
It's not your money.
It's not your big houses, not
your nice, designer clothes.
Because when you die, everything
goes back in the
box, including you.
So memories--
please make, please make
memories a top priority.
If you have great memories, you
will always have a place
to go when times are tough.
And the last is tradition.
Give your family something that
lives on long after you.
Maybe, your parents have
done that for you.
That's three greatest gifts
you can give to
your family, I believe.
Now life is fun, and
fun is good.
I can tell you right now.
I don't do anything anymore
that's not fun.
I just won't do it.
And if I can make it
fun, I don't do it.
If this not fun, or I can't
make it fun, I'm out.
Focker out.
OK.
So we run our baseball teams.
This is our--
we just have been approached
by a reality show on how we
run our business-- like we need
another one of those.
A reality show, the want to do
a reality show on how we run
our baseball teams.
Because we're very famous for
how we run our baseball teams.
We're very successful.
Our baseball team's in the top
10 best service companies in
North America.
We've sold every ticket
to every game for the
last 12 to 13 years.
Most of people who started
with us are still there.
And believe me, we don't give
them Google salaries.
And when they came in and
said, well, how you it?
How do you do this?
They said, let's see
your strategy.
Where's you're 10
year strategy?
I go, strategy?
We hand them a piece of
paper that says--
They go, how do you do--
We hand them a piece of paper
that says, fun is good.
The go, that's it?
Yeah, if it was any
more than that.
It wouldn't be fun I'm not going
to write more than that.
So we're famous for
our promotions.
Here are some of the
ones we have done.
Some of them need explanation,
I'll grant you that.
Nobody night.
Charleston, South Carolina.
We went for the lowest
attendance in the history
professional sports--
not something most professional
organizations
shoot for but one of our folks
said, hey, why don't we go for
the lowest attendance
in history of
professional sports.
We looked at up in Guinness
Book of World Records.
The current record was four.
Must have been the old
Atlanta Hawks.
I'm not sure.
But--
so we decided to pick a game.
And we didn't tell the fans.
They just showed up.
And we locked all the
stadium doors.
They couldn't get in.
But outside we had bands and
carnival-like atmosphere.
And we had the Cooperstown
Baseball
Hall of Fame was there.
ESPN was there.
It was all over the wire.
And at the end of the fifth
inning, we let them in.
And now we have the lowest
attendance in the history of
professional sports.
We have zero and we're
quite proud of that.
Vasectomy, not on Father's
Day, Night--
We weren't really going
to do that.
It was just a joke.
But unfortunately it got
carried by the UPI.
And people started--
I mean it really
got some legs.
And just, phew.
Everybody was--
every major news network
was on it.
So we're going, do I think
we should get a
urologist at the game?
You know some nut's going to
have a bag of nachos and
probably a bratwurst and say, I
had big beer, and I'll have
a vasectomy while I'm here.
So we actually pulled that.
Mime Night, we did.
We did that in Brockton because
the umpires decided
that we could no longer so
controversial plays on the big
scoreboard.
So people liked controversial
plays.
So we said, well, how are
we going to do it?
So we decided to hire mimes
to reenact plays
on the dug-out roof.
Because nobody likes mimes.
And there's plenty of them.
So we got mimes.
And it was so funny.
Because this is Brockton.
Brockton's a tough town, the
home of Marvelous Marvin
Haggler, the home of
Rocky Marciano.
It's a tough town.
So this play goes on,
and these mimes
start to reenact it.
They're going--
like this.
And you could see audience
going, what?
And then finally, one guy stands
up and flings a hot dog
and hits the mime right
in the head.
And it was like a zillion
light bulbs went on.
And they go, well, must
be why they're there.
They're targets.
Within a second, 50,000
hot dogs started
flying out the stands.
We sold out of every hot
dog in 20 minutes.
I'm not kidding you.
And after getting pelted for
about five minutes, the mimes
were gestures to the audience
that weren't very
mime-like, I might add.
Arthur Anderson Night--
When Arthur Anderson
was having math
problems with the IRS--
they were under investigation
for tax fraud.
We did a tribute Arthur
Anderson that night.
For every ticket you bought for
$8, we give you a receipt
for $30 for tax purposes, as a
tribute to Arthur Andersen.
At every one of our stadiums
we have a hot tub.
You can have a hot tub party,
watch the ball game.
We have in St. Paul--
St. Paul Saints-- we
have a 90 year old
nun that gives massages.
I know that sounds so wrong
when I say that.
But it really does.
I get shivers.
But she's a licensed masseuse.
People love her.
We have a pig that delivers
baseballs.
When the umpire needs a
baseball, the pig comes out
center field with two saddle
bags full of baseballs.
And he trots from center field
all the to home plate.
And they give him a
sugar treat, takes
the baseballs out.
And he trots all the way back.
But people go crazy.
They love it.
And then we just did Inflatable
Bat Night,
sponsored by Viagra.
That seemed to go
very, very well.
People enjoyed that.
But it's fun.
And that's why we do it.
Relationship Refinement--
couple last things here.
What I found to be very helpful
in my life, especially
as I get older, I don't have
time for people who waste my
time, people who suck the
life force out of me.
There are energy gainers.
There are energy drainers,
takers, and 1%ers.
Takers, unfortunately,
there's a lot of.
1%ers are people care as much if
not more about you as they
do themselves.
Energy gainers, I like
hanging around.
They make me feel better
about myself.
Energy drainers are people that
just suck the life force
out of you.
You feel worse when they've
been around you.
And I try to identify
frenemies early.
I try to figure out who--
I don't want to waste my time.
So there's four things I look at
when I decide who I'm going
to hang around, to try to
read the tea leaves.
I look at four things.
One, I try to observe how people
spend their money.
It tells me something
about them.
People vote with their money.
Do they buy things
or experiences?
Are they impulsive
or thoughtful?
Are they buying in abundance or
scarcity kind of mentality?
Then I look at their friends--
there's an old Sicilian saying,
show me who you hang
around and I will show
you who you are.
That tells me what kind of
friendships they have--
transactional or unconditional,
short
term or long term.
Then I look at how they
speak of themselves.
That tells me at ton.
What's their operating model?
Are they humble?
Or are they boastful?
Do hold a grudge?
Or are they forgiving?
Do they give credit
or take credit?
What's the balance of listening
versus talking?
We used to have a neighbor.
My father never liked her.
He goes, she has two gears,
talking and waiting to talk.
And so I says, that's a
pretty good one, dad.
Anyway.
And then the last thing I look
at is I observe how do they
treat people and things
they don't need.
How do they treat kids,
senior citizens,
relatives, service people?
How do they do that?
I was over at one acquaintance's
house, and
their 12-year-old was acting up,
was so rude at the table.
I couldn't believe it.
And the mother thought she
needed to address it.
She goes, oh--
he even swore at table.
She goes, oh, that's
our little Timmy.
He's very opinionated.
I go, little Timmy's
is going to jail.
[LAUGHTER]
GARY KUNATH: You better
fix him before he
robs me in 10 years.
So all I have to say is this--
you get what you
accept in life.
And to me, happiness is
the ultimate currency.
Those who wish to sing
always find a song.
The two most important days in
your life are the day you are
born and the day you
discover why.
And life is like riding a
10-speed bike, most of us have
gears we've never used.
And the this next one came
directly from Willie Nelson.
He told me this.
Doesn't matter how heavy
something is, what matters is
how long you have to hold.
It I don't know what he meant.
It may have been a doobie.
I'm not sure what he was
thinking about there.
Things that surprise me
most about people.
We get bored with childhood.
We rush to grow up.
And then we long to become
children again.
We lose our health to
try to make money.
And then we lose our money to
try to get back our health.
We live as it will never die.
And we die as though
we've never lived.
And we don't understand that a
rich person is not the one who
makes the most, but it's the
one who needs the least.
The best things in life
are not things.
And what I really want you to
understand is, don't ever
forget why it is you
do what you do.
I know you work hard.
You do.
I know.
But don't forget why
you work hard.
The best definition, to me,
success is applause at home.
And I'll end with this--
the eulogy.
I saw a man who stood to speak
at the funeral of a friend.
He referred to the dates on
the tombstone from the
beginning to the end.
He noted the first date
was her birth.
And the second was
when she passed.
He said, we never truly
know just how
long lives might last.
Then he paused a bit, trying
to fight back his tears.
And then he said, what truly
matters, though, is the dash
between those years.
For that dash represents
all the time we
spent alive on earth.
And only those who've loved you
can know what that little
line is worth.
Then he said, it matters not how
much we own, the cars, the
house, the cash.
What matters most is how we live
and how we love and how
we spend that dash.
So think about this long and
hard, are the things you'd
like to change.
For you never know how much time
is left that can still be
rearranged.
So when your eulogy is read.
And your life's actions to
rehash, would you be proud of
the things they say about
how you spend your dash.
Thank you very much.
Let me turn it over to Ben.
You guys have been great
to hang with me.
I know you guys-- you're
running and
gunning all the time.
But thank you.
[APPLAUSE]